quando gabriella mi ha proposto questa
straordinaria avventura che il ted
la prima cosa che ho provato è stata
paura cosa che prova ancora adesso
poi ho provato entusiasmo e infine molto
pragmaticamente ho scritto
l'appuntamento su questa agenda verde
fino a pochi secondi fa prima di salire
sul palco parlare al ted era soltanto
una proposta è una scritta su un'agenda
l'evento che ora sta accadendo in questo
momento non era ancora avvenuto ma solo
in questo momento proprio ora è proprio
qui sta accadendo davvero non ci posso
credere ma ora non è più futuro e
presente questa semplice esperienza che
ciascuno di noi fa ogni giorno senza
rendersene conto
suggerisce che il futuro non è un luogo
che esiste da qualche parte e che
contiene i nostri desideri e le nostre
speranze
i nostri timori con un armadio pieno di
vestiti che possiamo indossare quando lo
vogliamo
il futuro è piuttosto un orizzonte che
in qualche modo e da qualche parte c'è
ma che si allontana man mano che lo
raggiungiamo e questa strada la natura
del futuro espressa dalla stessa parola
futuro infatti è il verbo essere latino
coniugato al futuro e significa che sarà
che sarà per essere questa parola indica
allora due aspetti che qualcosa sta per
realizzarsi che sta per arrivare non a
caso e in tedesco si dice zukunft in
arrivo ma proprio per questo non è
ancora non è pienamente
per questo un grandissimo filosofo
agostino d'ippona che come tutti i
grandi filosofi si è interrogato sulle
cose banali e inutili affermava che le
due dimensioni temporali come il passato
e il futuro fossero delle dimensioni
dell'anima che vive il presente ma che
ricorda il passato li aspetta il futuro
l'esperienza del futuro allora
l'esperienza dell'attesa ci proietta
fuori di noi in una dimensione temporale
che ancora non esiste
a differenza del passato però che non
può essere modificato in cui eventi sono
già avvenuti
il futuro proprio per il suo essere non
ancora provoca aspettative e sentimenti
come speranza pessimismo sfiducia
sentimenti che nessuno di noi proverebbe
per eventi già accaduti nel passato
attraverso l'esperienza del futuro noi
non siamo mai ogni in noi stessi ma
siamo sempre al di là il timore il
desiderio la speranza dice montagna ci
lanciano verso l'avvenire e ci tolgono
il sentimento e la considerazione di ciò
che soltanto veramente viviamo e cioè il
presente
per questo abbiamo bisogno di conoscere
il futuro è questo bisogno attraversato
tutta la storia dell'occidente è vero
che il futuro è un non ancora ma
contemporaneamente qualcosa che sta per
essere sta per arrivare appunto non ha
sicuramente tutta la straordinaria e la
luminosa evidenza del presente in cui le
cose sono qui davanti a me magari le
posso toccare o modificare ma come i
sogni dei grandi uomini dimostrano è
come se lo fosse non è un caso allora
che non si dica vedere il futuro ma
piuttosto prevedere il futuro per
vederlo prima prima che diventi presente
ma è possibile prevedere il futuro e
soprattutto cosa significa prevedere
prevedere significa controllare
conoscere in anticipo gli eventi
significa prepararsi in modo adeguato e
guidare il cambiamento a proprio
vantaggio
secondo la cultura filosofica e
scientifica del medioevo che il campo
che conosco meglio questo tipo di
conoscenza cioè prevedere gli eventi per
controllarli non era permesso a tutti la
maggior parte degli uomini subivano
passivamente le influenze delle leggi
della natura che determinavano non
soltanto i processi naturali ma anche le
decisioni e sentimenti soltanto il
filosofo attraverso la conoscenza dei
meccanismi della natura poteva prevedere
e controllare gli eventi invece di
essere dominato il filosofo domina guida
controlla la conoscenza e allora lo
strumento attraverso cui l'uomo legge la
realtà
la interpreta e la trasforma la storia
ci offre tantissimi esempi di donne e di
uomini che hanno saputo prevedere il
futuro non come qualcosa che doveva
necessariamente accadere ma come un
progetto da realizzare non prevedere ciò
che è necessario ma costruire ciò che
dovrebbe essere prevedere significa
allora anche avere fiducia
se io ho fiducia che qualcosa si
realizzerà allora questa aspettativa
questa attesa inevitabilmente si
riflette sul mio presente lo modifica e
lo trasforma e non importa che questo
qualcosa sia praticamente invisibile
agli altri gli altri diranno che
qualcosa è impossibile fino a quando non
arriva qualcuno che lo fa pensate
diritti civili di cui diamo che godiamo
e di cui chiediamo per scontati ci sono
stati tempi e ci sono luoghi in cui
questi diritti sono semplicemente la
certezza di donne e uomini che li
prevedono come se fossero presenti
davanti ai loro occhi e la tenacia la
forza la speranza la fiducia di questi
uomini e queste donne che trasformano
una visione è un'idea in progetto
rendendo presente qualcosa che ancora
presente non è non è un caso che idea e
visione in greco condividono la stessa
radice e una visione un prevedere che
vuole realizzarsi queste donne e questi
uomini trascinano nel loro presente
qualcosa che esiste soltanto in una
piccola agenda verde questo ci indica
che il futuro è parente prossimo della
speranza e della fiducia io cammino mi
metto in moto faccio in modo che le cose
accadano perché desidero che questo
accada ovvero io cammino perché sento di
avere un futuro o un futuro perché una
speranza e ho una speranza perché ho una
certezza perché credo in qualcosa
indipendentemente dal fatto che questo
qualcosa sia una battaglia per i diritti
civili
una straordinaria scoperta scientifica o
più modestamente un progetto di vita
uno studio che mi appassioni un lavoro
che mi gratifica
un amore una fede la fiducia è dunque il
conduttore capace di trasformare la
paura dell'ignoto che di fatto e
immobilismo assenza di futuro il
desiderio dell'ignoto in passione per
ciò che ancora non si conosce quindi
ricerca di quello che ancora non è
conosciuto la fiducia trasforma
l'imprevisto inopportunità montare lo
diceva in una poesia bellissima prima
del viaggio
l'imprevisto è l'unica speranza la
fiducia allora il legame tra il già il
presente e il non ancora il futuro e il
link necessario a trasformare il tempo
da cronologia in speranza
l'orizzonte temporale in orizzonte di
senso e il caronte che traghetta l'idea
dal pensiero alla realtà l'unico spazio
possibile dove l'idea prende forma e
diventa progetto lo sanno benissimo gli
studenti che studiano filosofia a cui è
dedicato questa brevissima conferenza
l'estero modo non può essere considerato
una variabile dipendente all'interno di
un sistema complesso che lo travolge ma
come una dinamica indipendente in grado
di guidare il sistema e di costruire il
mondo che verrà
soprattutto in momenti di crisi e di
apparente stallo come quello che noi
stiamo vivendo in questo momento è
necessario anzi fondamentale cambiare
l'approccio mentale sforzarsi di
guardare la realtà con occhi nuovi per
esplorare nuovi territori e scoprire
nuovi spazi nel gioco della domanda e
dell'offerta bisogna avere il coraggio
di porre domande nuove e pretendere
risposte diverse
come nel caso del ted dove diversi punti
di vista sono messe insieme come le
corde di una chitarra da un'unica
visione che diventa progetto comune
lasciatevi sorprendere e ponte da tutti
grazie